habemus papam nous avons un pape les
catholiques vont désormais célébrée
chaque jour françois à l'église saint
victor de guyancourt les fidèles étaient
déjà ému avant la messe ce jeudi midi
je viens pour le passé justement à dieu
pour l'élection de frappe
françois 1er je suis très heureuse pour
l'élection du nouveau pape parce que ça
donne une joie à l'église d'avoir un
parent d'un autre continent mais qui est
pour tout le monde
quelque chose de nouveau vous êtes
content oui madame
un moment fort partagé avec le jeune
père fabrice du et qui lie son premier
changement de souverain pontife
c'est une nouvelle figure pour laquelle
on va prier au quotidien qui va pouvoir
aussi donner certaines directions à
l'église et chaque papin arrivé avec ses
idées avec des projets pour l'église
donc ça va changer un certain nombre de
choses même s'il faut pas s'attendre à
une révolution majeure dans les quelques
semaines ce nouveau pape le pape
françois et ben imprimera l'histoire de
l'église à sa manière un pape jésuite
jesús ce sont des prêtres religieux qui
ont fait le voeu de pauvreté et qui
vivent de manière assez exigeante cette
pauvreté
françois ça fait référence à saint
françois d'assise saint françois
d'assise et le ce1 par excellence qui
incarne la vertu de la pauvreté qui
incarne aussi l'amour de la nature
l'amour le dialogue inter-religieux
françois saint françois avait été
discuté avec les musulmans à l'époque ce
dialogue était plus que complexe
donc ça dit déjà fortement quelque chose
de la manière dont il sera pas en chaque
messe le pape est nommé nomme le pape et
l'évêque
par leur prénom lors tout l'enjeu c'est
de pas se tromper pas mettre notre pape
benoît à ce moment là sa première fois
s'est bien passée et restera un souvenir
extraordinaire tout comme la découverte
du pape
hier soir au moment où j'ai appris peu
fumé et et blanc je recevais un couple
en préparation au mariage c'était dans
mon bureau au presbytère donc je leur ai
dit ce que je crois qu'ils ont appelée
halluciné mais je leur ai dit est ce
qu'on peut tout arrêter parce qu'il faut
qu'on voie le nouveau pape il faille
chercher une bouteille de champagne et
donc avec ce couple on a débouché la
bouteille de champagne accueilli le
nouveau pape et une fois seulement qu'on
savait qu'ils s'étaient j'ai fermé mon
ordinateur et on a pu continuer la
préparation au mariage